[Music]
[Applause]
the rehab
for nick wright will be for several
years perhaps after what happened with
the kansas city chiefs
and nick wright now known as nick wrong
this week co-host of first things first
on fox sports 1
joins us on the program uh refresh my
memory what were you saying about the
chiefs on friday going into the super
bowl oh i
i don't know if you actually need your
memory to refresh dan i
i saw the beginning of yesterday's show
you seem to remember it vividly
just a day ago i i had the shocking take
that the chiefs would win
i had the shocking take that the best
offense in the league over the last
three years would continue to function
and i was wrong
and you know i i understand that this is
the first time in your what is it at
this point
65-year broadcasting career that you've
ever had someone have an incorrect
prediction so i'm surprised a little bit
at the level you're reveling in it but
yeah i was wrong i was wrong dan
wait that sounded snarky nick i i
are you being snarky no no i wouldn't be
snarky i wouldn't i would never be
snarky when you know a broadcast hall of
famer leads his show the day after the
super bowl
potentially the most listened to viewed
day of your entire year
within 18 seconds at calling me what i
was called as a third grader
i understand this show does traffic in
pedantic childhood humor we're just you
know a few
steps above flatulence jokes on this
television radio program but
i thought nick wrong you know you know
so you could have changed
nick too there's a name that rhymes with
you could have gone for the whole boat
there if you wanted to
change my name mess with my name to lead
your show the day after the super bowl
that's fine
that's the type of broadcasting you do
wait were you called
dick wrong in in grade school
i i hope you get fined for that what i
hope there
i i hope you i hope right now
fritzy and paulie and all the guys are
nervous because
you're doing things you shouldn't do
wait
could i get in trouble for saying that
dick allen was a great player or dick
ebersol is one of the great
tv executives how about i call you
richard wrong
you know what why did i come on i do
why do i do this because you're a good
sport
that's why you're a good sport when did
you unlike you know who's not a good
sport
that tom brady taunting people and then
writing apology notes afterwards
you know who's not a good sport that
antoine winfield jr
antoine winfield senior would never do
what he did he's like oh tyree did it to
me
tyrique when he was running into the end
zone in week 12 was wishing peace be
upon you as you're taught
in you know catholic school growing up
it was a very different scenario than
what antoine winfield jr did
when did you know that you were in
trouble your chiefs were in trouble
well around the time fritzy text me to
make sure i would come on this week even
though the game wasn't over
that wasn't a good sign wait did he book
you during the game
during the game he was like if this
results
i
nick i did tell fritzy to wait and you
why did you do that i sent them a note
at halftime just to make sure that
we'll uh we'll see you monday i'm sorry
i apologize for that
i'm going to say it i'm not going to
text you i apologize okay
well i appreciate that that was sent
during halftime
i hear the weekend had a good
performance i can't confirm it
because i was pacing around my
neighborhood chain smoking black and
milds
trying to figure out what i was angriest
about was i angriest about
the the new definition of past
interference that applied to these
playoffs which is tom brady
in completions was i angriest about andy
reid
who i adore just deciding to just
continue to taunt tom brady with the
timeouts what are you doing calling
these timeouts
or was i angriest about the fact that
what might have been the single greatest
pass i've ever seen patrick mahomes
throw
on a third and 11 with a man in his face
and a man behind him
bounced off tyrek's face mask and i
didn't know what i was angriest about
but then i decided no i'm angry as to
todd fritz
that's why i'm angry okay hold on todd
what he's conveniently leaving after his
response to that text where he goes out
to say
i am going to frame this text and hang
it up on the wall or something along
those lines
after the chiefs come back and win
because i was too premature
to call it a game okay all right
i i respect the confidence it was you
know misplaced naive
but you know it's good to know you know
what you learn something new every day
and it's good to know because i learned
yesterday
that this show was the place for
juvenile humor
and i learned today that todd fritz is a
man
that's going to share private texts that
was not for publication
that was not that wasn't that i thought
that was between todd and i
do you think everyone has my cell phone
number todd i invited
that circle and now i'm gonna have to
change it or just block it no
see this is what happens when did you
start thinking about me
on sunday well
i was thinking about a lot on sunday dan
i i was thinking about the fact that
you know i've always heard that kids
that have to pay their way through
college
uh are more successful like they they
and i'm like well that'll be good for my
kids
because now i can't pay for it so i
thought about that
i was thinking about the fact that do
you realize
the perfect storm of events that had to
happen
for this like it's one thing for a guy
for many years to say i think tom brady
is finished
and my saving grace on that is you know
who agreed with me bill belichick
because he waved him goodbye
bill belichick's like you know what that
nick wright he makes some gays and good
takes
i like those statistical graphs pointing
down really bye to tom brady
and it's another thing for me to be like
hey this guy mahomes he's the most
talented player i've ever seen in my
life and the chiefs are gonna win three
in a row
but the fact that during the life of
those takes
it was never a possibility that brady
could beat mahomes in a super bowl so
they played the same conference
but then he had to leave the chiefs had
to make another super bowl
brady had somehow get there and then it
had
i so i was just thinking like this is
like
the this is the randy johnson's fastball
that killed the dove
of like perfect storm of suck for these
takes to all collide
and i'm the dove and tom brady's the
fastest
i'm so mad i'm so mad and you're so
happy
no but i like how you tried to do kind
of a
an end run and you said to fritzy hey
did dan pick the chiefs
and then fritzy had to tell you no i
picked the buccaneers
what a rat i'm such a rat you yeah
i really did think you picked the chiefs
no it's
yeah so i i've had the pivot i had the
under two
nick i had the under in the in the
buccaneers do you do you have you you
guys have a fancy social media team
yeah if you if you really wanted to
stick it to me what you could have put
up
was my tweet with the 11
prop bets i made before the game and you
missed them all didn't you
i went over 11. that's
that's hard to do not only is it hard to
do my friend let me tell you something
as someone a seasoned gambler when you
make 11 bets
if you're a responsible gambler you
think worst case scenario you're like
all right what if i go
three for eight if i'm minus five units
plus the vig can i can i stomach it
you're like okay i can bet in the right
amount you don't budget over 11.
it's not even a consent because one two
for nine you're only minus seven units
like ah that hurts
o for eleven dan you don't consider i
bet
over 38.5 yards for the
chief's shortest punt so over 38.5 yards
for the shortest pump with the logic
being
they're not going to punt inside the 40.
it was a sharp bet i was like i am on
the right side of this
that long-haired hippie punter we have
shanked that sucker
off one side and then shanked it off the
other side
he had two 28-yard punt
yeah sorry if you called you a hippie
and by the way
uh get nick wright at
get nick wright that's your twitter yeah
but we just found out that at
get dick wrong is available so that is
so that now do you want us to grab
paulie would you grab that yeah i'll
grab a fridge
dick wrong no uh at get dick wrong oh my
bad yes okay
[Laughter]
you guys are really enjoying this yeah
hey
you're coming off great you know
we might not but you're coming off great
okay
thanks i'm financially insulted
my hey you went out and bought a
beautiful
red blazer velvet
velvet blazer custom-made how much was
that blazer
it was a thousand seventy four dollars
dan
i would like for you i was gonna pay for
it with all my chief clinics
oh oh your prop bets all your prop bets
all the punter bets you were gonna pay
for your blazer oh
you know what maybe wear it when uh the
buccaneers have their parade their
victory parade
it's not it is here's the thing you want
to know something
god i'm going to share this with you and
then it'll be a good it'll be a final
thing to share with you and then we'll
do you want to text it to fritzy and
then he'll share it with me no
i don't okay the store i went into
had that red velvet blazer
in a slightly different hue of red
that i thought was too close to the box
color
that instead i had i saw they had a
different piece of clothing
in the chief's red and i was like can
you custom make me that blazer in that
fabric he's like it's gonna be like
double the price
i'm like no problem i've got it let's do
it
stupid blazer it just hangs in my closet
now taunts me never to be worn
do the chiefs rebound from this yeah
i might not but they would yeah
more likely to get back to the super
bowl next year chiefs or bucks
i think it's pretty here's the thing in
all seriousness i think it's pretty
clearly the chiefs in this regard
there's no one in the afc that has shown
they can beat mahomes
he's never lost to josh allen he's never
lost a lamar he's never lost a baker
the only young good quarterback that's
ever beaten him is deshawn
and deshawn's leaving like i assume
leaving the conference
and so i just the i think herbert is
going to be really good
but that's i don't think they're ready
yet i just think the nfc is so much
tougher now brady's got an easier
division now all of a sudden
because brees is assuming we assume i
think brees is done
and so i don't think that division is
that good but the ram should be good we
know the seahawks will be good the
packers will be good
so i i just think it's a tougher road
and i think the chiefs i
i i'm going to go ahead and say this i
think the chiefs are better than the
bucks i understand
i have no evidence to prove it but i
think the chiefs over the course of a
season are the better team and so
i think the chiefs are more likely to be
back you're a good sport and uh
thanks for joining us and we'll talk to
you next football season
dan you're okay paulie mclovin
you guys are fine fritz you're going to
hear from my attorney
i have to patch up i got to get the
trust back it's terrible thank you nick
bye all right that's nick right fox
sports one
must viewing every uh monday through
friday yeah